yeah  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  I had two tiny cluster - girl versus  brown technical background check  background when I get  I tried to [ __ ] up but I'm here for the  crown crown  [Music]  take it  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Faceman jackin it wind capital get ready  so comparison trigger like Marion Jones  on the steroids y'all [ __ ] slow as the  heroine high ahead of here ahead of you  I had to let it go  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  the pain bird and copy the shame with a  dream we would have fortune and fame um  and then the bait come in the a painter  crane Bain I need to Jemaine  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  I had me tightly puffed up but I'm here  for the crown crown oh [ __ ] I was a [ __ ]  trying to [ __ ] I'll put them here for  the crown  [Applause]